[موسيقى]
مشينا
سواء الطينه ليالينا
[موسيقى]
معقول الفراق
اني انا ااسس هاي الفرقه النسائيه
الحقيقه ولكن لاقت استحسان من اول يوم
انطلقت فيه على مسرح المركز الثقافي
الملكي الناس اللي بره كانت اكثر من اللي
جوا
حسيت انه فعليا انا في مجتمع داعم للمراه
الموسيقيه وهذا كان الهدف انه تمكين
المراه موسيقيا
هالليله حلوه
حلوه وجمي
له الفكره بتاسيس هاي الفرقه النسائيه مش
جندريه احنا بعيدين عن الفصل بين الذكر
والانثى لانه احنا كفرقه بنعزف للذكر
الذكر بيجهز لنا المسرح مهندس صوت الحقيقه
الصعوبه في تشكيل هذا الفريق كانت في
البدايه انه البنات مش حاسين انه هم
قادرين لانه ما عمرهم جرب يعني بفتره من
فترات صار يقولوا لي خلينا نجيب فلان
يقودنا خلينا نجيب فلان يتاكد انه احنا
تمام انا الهدف كان انه
اخلي البنات واثقين من نفسهم اكثر لا انتم
قادرين لا ما بدنا نجيب حد احنا اللي بدنا
نقود حالنا واحنا اللي بدنا نكمل يعني هاي
المسيره مع بعض فبتحسي انه حتى البنات
طريقه عزفهم اختلفت طريقه ادائهم على
المسرح اختلفت
[موسيقى]
بتلاقي انه فرق نسائيه للنساء فقط ولكن
نايا ما كانت هيك ابدا يعني ما عمرنا مثلا
عزفنا فقط للنساء هي بدها تكون موجوده على
مسرح ويجي جمهور واسع من كافه الفئات
العمريه انه يحضروا الفرقه لانه رساله هاي
الفرقه هي نشره تراث ونوعيه الموسيقى اللي
دخلنا في تقديمها اللي هي الكلاسيكيات
العربيه
المرشحات
الاغاني التراثيه من الشمال الى الجنوب من
الشرق الى الغرب
تفتح ش
مال وانا
وانا في كريح الشمالي
في هاي الفتره اللي هي عشرين 23 احنا
صادفنا كثير من المناسبات الملكيه العزيزه
على قلوبنا بدايه في عرس الاميره ايمان
واللي توجه لنا دعوه للفرقه وكانت دعوه
جدا مهمه
لاحياء حنا الاميره ايمان هون احنا توجهنا
لانه نكون نساء تعزف للنساء لانه الفكره
ننشر تراثنا لانه انت بتعرفي اذا مناسبه
الملكيه الكل راح يشوف واجا تجديد الثقه
من قبل جلاله الملكه في فرقه نايا بانها
تستدعينا لحفل عقد قران الامير ولكن
بالعزف هاي المره مش في الغناء برضو حتى
نوعيه الاغاني المختاره كانت من اغانينا
الوطنيه القديمه واغانينا التراثيه
الخطه المستقبليه ان شاء الله لانه احنا
هلا اسسنا جمعيه الماسس نايا
ونبلش انه ندرب وندرس فتيات حتى ستات كبار
ان شاء الله هاي الخطه ب 23 راح تتحقق